le conseil départemental siège au sein
de l'office de développement de
l'agriculture des régions d'outre-mer en
tant que qualité avec cette compétence
qui est la note de défendre les intérêts
du monde agricole à la réunion donc deux
fois par an nous nous retrouvons en
conseil d'administration pour aborder
l'ensemble des sujets qui concernent
essentiellement les filières organisées
puisque notamment l'office a pour objet
de gérer les enveloppes du ciom mais
également du poséidon qs est un moment
important et aujourd'hui par exemple
dans ce conseil d'administration nous
débattons sur l'évaluation des
politiques publiques notamment en lien
avec le posei et le ministère vient de
nous rappeler ministère de l'agriculture
que l'europe est très vigilante et très
exigeante par rapport à cette
utilisation des fonds du posei et nous
sommes rentrés maintenant dans une
période d'évaluation
ils nous voient falloir donc justifié
bien sur l'utilité des aides qui nous
ont été accordés et puis surtout montré
que c est du posei ont permis aux
régions ultramarines de gagner en
qualité aussi bien en qualité produits
mais également dans la diversification
des produits et à voir par exemple une
action très forte en direction de
l'agriculture biologique donc ça fait
partie je dirais des objectifs qu'on
sait nous fixer à travers un pays 2030
au niveau du conseil départemental de la
réunion nous sommes donc en phase avec
ces orientations européennes
nous profitons également de ce conseil
d'administration qui est adossé au salon
international de l'agriculture pour
venir faire la promotion du savoir-faire
réunionnais et les 600 mètres carrés du
village réunion sera ouvert dès demain
et accueillera bien évidemment
l'ensemble des visiteurs mais nous
attendons aussi particulièrement cette
année une visite des politiques et
notamment des différents candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
ça sera un temps fort puisque nous
aurons l'occasion d'échanger avec eux
une autre vision de l'agriculture à la
réunion nous avons bien évidemment
agrippé 2030 mais on aimerait aussi
obtenir l'adhésion de l'ensemble des
candidats sur ce projet porté par les
réunionnaises et des réunionnais portés
par nos agriculteurs et tout le monde
agricole de la règle je profite
également de ce moment pour a invité
l'ensemble des réunionnaises et
réunionnais qui se trouvent dans la
région ile de france mais pas seulement
tous celles et ceux qui sont ici en
france métropolitaine venir retrouver
des saveurs de l'île de la réunion venir
découvert également la production de
l'île de la réunion sur notre stand
notre village réunions avec nos pagnes
trois exposants présents et c'est un
moment aussi pour nous de partager ce
moment de convivialité avec
nono réunionnaises et de réunionnais
présents ici en france